hey what's up guys it's marquez from the
mkbhd channel back with another hd video
today we're going to be taking a look at
a very popular web browser called google
chrome you've probably already heard of
it but i want you to go ahead and take a
look at the current version of google
chrome you might be running and then i
want you to take a look at the title
yeah today we're going to take a look at
google chrome 15 one of the latest
release builds and i have a link in the
description where you can check out how
to get the latest version and we're
going to go ahead and take a look at one
of the very interesting new features of
google chrome 15.
to check your version of chrome hit that
wrench and click about google chrome you
can see by that that we are running our
latest alpha version which is version
15. if you want to check out this super
super alpha version you can check the
description where there should be a
download link so one of the bigger
changes though not the biggest changes
of chrome 15 is the new interface to
select what chrome features sync with
your google account this opens a new tab
that has a little window in it that lets
you choose to sync extensions themes
bookmarks or even everything all these
checked items will show up across all
your computers running chrome and all of
your chrome os devices so that's pretty
cool
this feature's actually been available
in previous versions of chrome it's just
been a little bit more difficult to find
and the interface wasn't as pretty but
by far the coolest new feature in chrome
15 is the interface when you open a new
tab so hitting this new tab button or
control t for short will bring in this
cool visual panel interface that lets
you choose between most visited sites
chrome web apps and bookmarks
interestingly enough bookmarks are quote
coming soon so let's hope this feature
is activated quickly but it's really
nice to see this nice little interface
tweak and it's really been a pleasure to
use so far and the newest version of
chrome
also down in the lower right hand corner
is that familiar recently closed tabs
menu so overall i think everything is
very nicely spaced out especially for
people working on laptops or with
smaller screens i personally hope this
type of touch can come to maybe the new
window of android tablets it seems very
touch friendly don't you think either
way this new video is for those of you
guys who are using google chrome in the
recent form friday episode i asked what
browser you are using and a lot of you
guys use chrome so let me know if you
like this new feature are you looking
forward to the stable version of chrome
15 or do you already have it let me know
thanks for watching guys and i'll talk
to you guys in the next video
peace
you